OK. If the exons are in purple, I count, one,
two, three, four, five, six, seven. You should be able to
count the same up here. One, two, three, four, five, six,
seven. The number of introns we can't count in the mRNA
but we see them up here in the gene. One, two,
three, four, five, six. And you'll notice a pattern. Whenever you
have to count the number of exons and introns in a
gene, there'll always be one less intron than there are exons.
If there's one exon, then there'll be zero
introns. If there are two exons, there'll be one
intron. Now for some of you advanced learners
out there, there's some mixing and matching of exons.
In certain genes, that's a pretty advanced level
concept. But right now for most of us just
learning this, it's generally true that however many exons
we have in a gene, there's one fewer intron.